bonsoir à vous deux voies alors emmanuel
est-ce que c'est pas un pari très risqué
pour monsieur duceppe à quatre mois
d'une campagne électorale s'il ya
vraiment le temps d'insuffler un nouveau
souffle au parti
c'est la question que tout le monde se
pose mais dans le constat d'échec du
chef monsieur beaulieu voit que celui ci
avait réussi à garder mobiliser le noyau
dur qui l'avait porté à la tête du bloc
québécois les purs et durs si vous
voulez mais qui avait pas réussi à
percer ce noyau là l'espoir c'est bien
sûr que monsieur duceppe avec sa
notoriété sa maîtrise des dossiers sa
popularité le respect qu'il inspirait
lui va réussir à permettre au moins au
bloc à s'imposer dans le débat politique
sur la scène fédérale faut comprendre
aussi que dans bien des cercles
bloquiste encore à ce jour on voit les
résultats de 2011 comme un accident de
parcours qui aurait jamais dû arriver et
qui pourrait facilement être corrigés
on est en 2015 les démocrates seraient
les premiers à vous dire que eux ont
plutôt réussi à bien s'implanter au
québec mais ça sera bien sûr une partie
de la joute qui sent bien là dans les
prochains mois oui et sébastien
évidemment au parti québécois on avait
peur que le bloc au fond s'effondre avec
mario beaulieu et nuisent comme ça au
mouvement sont promises y avait une
réelle préoccupation parce qu'il est
coin sur l'organisation du bloc
québécois et les résultats électoraux de
l'élection à venir et donc pierre karl
péladeau sans faire nécessairement des
compressions a été consulté par gilles
duceppe pour son retour en politique
et monsieur péladeau a appuyé judiciaire
monsieur voulait s'assurer qu'il leur
ait l'appui du parti québécois parce que
c'était important pour lui pour la suite
des choses à il a consulté pierre karl
péladeau est ce que monsieur péladeau
craignaient avec mario beaulieu comme
chef du bloc québécois
c'était que le momentum qu'il a réussi
justement lui monsieur péladeau a
insufflé dans une certaine mesure au
mouvement souverainiste au québec avec
la visibilité qu'il a reçus dans la
course à la direction du parti québécois
s'est formé avec le bloc québécois qui
aurait pu avoir des résultats électoraux
difficile alors ils voulaient poursuivre
ce momentum et faire en sorte que ce
momentum la dure un peu plus longtemps
qu'eux
de là les élections fédérales mais
est-ce que c'était au point de faire des
pressions sur mario beaulieu pour qu'il
se retire il n'y a pas eu de putsch
organisé fomenté par le parti québécois
mais disons que on est content que mario
beaulieu se retire il ya une joie on va
l'appeler contenu du parti québécois
parce que justement la base militante
aurait pu être démobilisés par mario
beaulieu alors qu'elle va être
probablement plus mobilisés par gilles
duceppe et cette base militante qu'elle
soit en bloc ou au parti québécois
c'est la même alors on veut mobiliser
ces gens là et avec je le dis c'est
pourtant ce que ça va réussir
emmanuel comment ce retour de gilles
duceppe dont va se traduire la son
échiquier politique
mais le pari c'est que l'arrivée de
gilles duceppe permettent d'augmenter
les appuis du bloc juste suffisamment
pour qu'ils redeviennent compétitifs et
si le bloc m'ont un peu ça fait que bien
des comtés où on va se retrouver avec
des courses à 3 et surtout dans certains
coins dans des courses à 4 écoles une
course à quatre ça prend pas 50 %
d'appuis pour gagner en compte et s'en
prend 27 29 30% ce qui pourrait
permettre au bloc québécois de faire
certaines percée par ailleurs la façon
dont ça va se matérialiser sur
l'ensemble de l'échiquier politique au
québec n'est pas uniforme parce que ça
dépend des forces en présence des
transferts d'appui bien sûr dans les
régions où le [ __ ] était fort et où le
bloc le dg était dans le passé l'est de
l'île de montréal une montée du bloc le
plus sérieusement compliqué la tâche ou
npd met par ailleurs prenez la région de
québec
dans ce col à la montée des
conservateurs était partiellement
attribuable à la faiblesse du bloc
alors là si le bloc remonte dans la
région de québec c'est plutôt l'effet
contraire si aux conservateurs que ça
peut nuire
vous voyez ce sont toutes des effets
dominos qui sont différents dépendant
des courses des comptes et ce qui fait
que ça va être palpitante
suivent et qu'une partie de cette joute
là qui va se jouer vraiment sur le
terrain grâce aux machines électorales
des oh et des ah oui ça pourrait causer
des surprises et donc cette annonce
demain matin 10h30 on va tous à
surveiller ça avec beaucoup d'intérêt
merci beaucoup à vous deux très bien roi